hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The
Crooked Man now we've got all the pieces
we got mi LF a y family that spells out
family okay so we need to put family
into the box and then we need to open
the box and see what horrors
it contains which I'm going to assume is
a lot of horreur okay then right oh my
god I don't care if it's honest work I
don't know I wanna no no oh no no oh
you're eating the baby model don't look
oh don't look you got a kid with you
really oh oh oh are you looking yeah
yeah he noticed you cuz your two-step
from him mr. David you're an idiot oh my
head no really really God you gotta be
joking me that is the stupidest thing
okay all right I'm just gonna say I've
seen a lot of dumb things in gaming a
lot of dumb gaming logic guy I've seen a
lot of dumb gaming logic that was the
dumbest I'm not even joking that was the
dumbest I've ever seen in my entire life
hey hey what you doing up there what's
that monster that I've been running away
from this entire game doing over there
and I'm not close enough let me just let
me just you okay you eating a barn right
in the face what um
let me just take a nap so I can go
faster how long that that'll make just
as much sense of why the hell you just
did okay so where is he going
a screw that kid I don't need them
anymore
I'm going to open this freakin box I
don't care where you went I don't care I
don't care where you in I'm going to
open the box because that is what I set
out to do yeah that's what I'm gonna do
it smells family you douche bear huh
ma'am
family can you tell me what it smells
that's wrong you're a [ __ ]
okay got it
what's in the box got a safe key well
how about that yeah you'll be fine kid
don't care about the safe right now of
course I care about the safe right now
is he in the basement is the venison rub
though this is this room job you're the
top floor maybe you went up to the roof
that would make sense
lay on let me check the top floor here
oh goes those low my head is bleeding
my head's bleeding no one makes me bleed
my own blood
aha gotcha
no I don't wanna I don't want any stay
away
hey that's a little meat I have to do
something about that thing yeah this is
a [ __ ] you hey hey hey hey what's going
on here hi hey could you see this master
here hi hey y'all right good I was going
on over here hey hey hey hey hey oh I
can't handle it I can't handle it
game logic game logic I can't handle it
it's too funny
it's funny really funny I like it it's
really funny I'm just gonna stand in
between hey hey what's going on new
Billy Oh what you doing what you doing
over here have two dudes over above that
leg Lou loading what do I got
what do I got how do I got lighter light
it on fire
oh well that's not right either what am
I supposed to do ah what am I supposed
bash it over the head or something huh
loot something well can't find anything
guess the kids just gonna die maybe we
could spray with the fire extinguisher
maybe maybe that is it and and wait no
aah oh hey you [ __ ] you live I'm gonna
go get this fire extinguisher and spray
you up the butt I'm gonna grab it I'll
use it get that monster really oh you
hit him with it okay yeah I'll run away
you [ __ ] really it ran away cuz I hit
it with a fire extinguisher
yeah I know I know I know oh I know you
don't need to tell me I know mr. David I
fell down
you
huh it's not your fault don't be
distraught maybe I shouldn't say this
but this kind of thing happens all the
time if we had noticed a little sooner
Oh little kiddies crying ugh
mr. David I thought you were dead
did I pass out head still hurts damn
monster are you really okay
yeah fluffy I'm fine you're not hurt
nope
I'll be fine too sorry for worrying you
looks like that monster went away for
some reason Luffy stop crying I want my
mama
I don't like monsters I don't like the
dark
you shouldn't little Billy the dark eyes
monsters I'm sure your mother's there
the police didn't read the first line I
told mom I'd wait mama said she was
proud of me so uh-huh
a wait for her mama wouldn't lie he's
going to come for me so I have to wait
here how long have you been waiting here
kid he really should be with the police
but he won't just won't listen if I try
to force him he'll just run I'll give it
a little more time then I'll force him
to go if I have to I do wonder what his
mom's doing though leaving her son
behind like this I can't believe some
people
what's that monster up to he was chasing
me before but now he's just after fluffy
huh I don't think I can possibly know I
just need to protect him from being
attacked maybe I should find a weapon
somewhere maybe in that safe downstairs
there's a gun with like a lot of
calibers like many many gauges
well not that many gauges cuz the lower
the gauge of the shock and the bigger
the blade you're really great I bet your
mom is proud of you hold out a little
more okay I'll stay with you
no more monsters can't promise that but
I'll protect you if you there are so
don't wander away from me okay okay I'll
stand with you mister if you say so
alright so I'm still injured but at
least I'm moving at a good piece I
didn't put the pieces in the puzzle
because my my save broke did so I gotta
redo that spell out family or somehow
get family to spell out murder which I'm
sure that I could accomplish if I really
put my mind to it huh
yeah hey can you tell me what the net
it's our mu dick you too slow oh oh it's
a R 2 beta tie everybody now together
it's odd elk and then why family unlock
the box got it a safe key why did I care
about the puzzle but not about this date
before if there's gun in here I could
have I would be very upset there's a gun
there's a gun I could've shot the
frickin stupid son of a [ __ ] ah
okay I have a gun now what
huh what is not fair
Oh stupid-ass monster help mr. David
help you're my only hope
this monsters damn persistent lover suck
this down monster I don't wanna I don't
wanna you don't want to what let me get
over here don't let that monster come
near you it's already burning oh come on
fluffy fluffy I had a gun gotta go after
fluffy where did he go what did he do
now this time I bet he went up to the
roof that's just my guess my gas my gas
lovey lovey lovey fluffy Hawaii there we
go okay I figured it at all and no no no
no stay away mr. David help over here
are they don't let it get near run away
mr. David help did he really go ahh run
away dammit
it really is after fluffy why listen
don't let it catch you run away I'll
take care of it okay I
oh I get to shoot it instead of stab it
I'm gonna shoot you so good about
Wow I'll catch it kid kid Oh kid damn it
[ __ ] kit I shot the kid damn it well
we all knew that was gonna happen sooner
or later I can't really be blamed for
this okay like a horrible two-step tango
okay no kid kid okay I'm gonna go over
here kid you're gonna get kid kid what
the hell are you doing kid get kid
oh don't walk in front of bullets kid
okay kid we're doing ya got ya I did not
shoot the kid think yeah suck that down
this is the end
don't come near fluffy again monster
maroush putted you right off the
freaking roof wow I'm tough I don't know
how many times I shot at it but not even
it could pant but not even I could pant
what fluffy I'm sorry you had to go
through that but it's all okay now
fluffy what's wrong were you hurt Oh
what what why uh-huh I it's so scary but
I I keep hanging in there and I I just
want to go home what's wrong kid you're
freaking me out a little bit so why
won't mama come this mama hate me fluffy
mama hates me so she'll never come back
for me I'm just an unwanted kid fluffy
that's not true it's not it that's not
you you I'm going to mr. policeman
finally you got some sense kid huh
well okay I'll go with you I'm fine I
can go there myself fluffy you shouldn't
be alone late at night I'm a tough kid
you can make it on my own
even if mama isn't there even if mama
isn't there I won't cry wha Oh
ow my ear my head feels like it's gonna
splud
well fluffy hell happened he left on his
own what no fluffy your mother didn't
hate you it was you who lost faith in
her what have I been doing here
wandering these ruins looking for a man
I don't know I should go home there's no
point to this nothing nothing will
change if you say so man that was the
last climactic battle maybe probably not
I had him going home F this hospital F
all of this after these shades in front
of my eyes sorry my eyes suddenly went
dark
just like Fluffy's eyes hmm what's going
on am I really just going home that
can't be that easy I kicked it off the
roof he's got to be down here okay huh
Wow came from the what clinic side I
don't know where the clinic side is no
is that where all the patients are I'm
in assume so uh where where where
we're in here no no that was loud
how am I supposed to know where she is
no no no okay where did I first find
fluffy that's probably where it is I
first found fluffy in this room here the
story to cafeteria thing no she's not
here where the hell are you lady
oh god no really I got no clue to where
she is you're not gonna give me anything
nothing really go to the go to the
clinic side there's kitties here but
nothing Clinic side where the hell is it
ever mind I don't know maybe this isn't
the clinic side I don't know there's
probably that's probably not the clinic
side the clinic side is probably where I
was before that's probably it okay so
there's got to be something here I'm
hearing this throughout the entire
Hospital so no no maybe one of these
places open up no bathroom no no
basement is where fluffy was singing no
aha oh oh is this a bunch of bass who's
that over there I don't know who is that
who is that Hey
but mom what what Davey
why do you abandon me it's not mom how
can you be here oh I hate hospitals
you're my family yet you abandoned me no
you were sick mom so so you left me my
own family couldn't stand me anymore no
you're wrong
Oh No but really who are you my mom
couldn't possibly be here why are you
pretending to be her it hurts Davey just
like it did then what what are you gonna
try to kill me again
what what
what
much baby
okay all right then if you say so
who are you why are you in my house what
did you do with my husband answer me mom
please stop you kept saying things like
that
dad just went out okay did you forget
shut up intruder I don't know anyone
like you I'll call the police on you
stop it
don't tell me you're already going
senile please take a rest for today I'm
tired from work just tell me if I'm a
bother
shut up keep your mouth shut do you
think I know you get out of here
stop Oh what are you saying did I do
something wrong
please just tell me if I did something
wrong are you teasing me because it's
not funny please mom
quiet I'm not your mother I don't know
you get out enough Oh
murder somebody murderer David hey what
are you doing
hey stop let go are you trying to kill
her David
it appears to be a brain tumor it's
putting too much pressure on her brain
sudden changes in behavior violent
action and memory loss can be signs of
brain illness it's not your fault don't
be distraught in some cases counseling
to resolve friction in a family can
uncover an illness maybe I shouldn't say
this but this kind of thing happens all
the time
hey that's from that note if we had
noticed a little sooner back to the
topic of your mother she appears to be
very weak we'll have to postpone the
operation for now we've hospitalized her
for the time being and her condition
will influence our decision hopefully it
won't be long please come by to see her
often even if she doesn't seem to know
you she is family
no we're not family anymore don't don't
say we are if I hadn't been stopped just
like that I would have
I would never have been forgiven for it
there really was hatred in me and it's
true I've abandoned her in the hospital
she was my only family my precious
family who I cared for me after my
father left in yet I
my wishes never came true my dreams love
and even family all go awry I can't have
anything that's not crooked
searching for I don't have to anymore
it's obvious now
there was only one way from the
beginning
scene three okay so there was my way mom
or what do I say what central hospital
fluffy what wait a minute whoa hey whoa
say what now
what what damn it David hasn't answered
a single call what is he up to and where
Paul what do we do I knew we shouldn't
have left David alone Marian get ahold
of yourself calm down how can I be calm
about this David's so worn out from
things with his mother and Shirley he's
even suffering over old wounds I was
always scared for him scared that he'd
do something there was no turning back
from I suggested moving to get his mind
clear but that didn't help now did it
it wasn't a bad idea but it was a
mistake for me to pick that place huh
damnit I'll call again if he doesn't
answer what oh thanks Italy president
what do you mean why would the room ah
don't tell me you go story at a time
like this always talking about how you
see things and huh
David David where are you dot-dot-dot
Central Hospital
why are you way over there listen I'm
going there so wait for me don't so much
as move a muscle
don't come please don't leave me alone
and why'd you answer the phone David
David hey David dammit I take about a
day to get that place on my motorcycle
Marion I'm going to see David I'm going
with you David is my friend too I can't
just ignore him at a time like this
alright let's go
broom broom I really don't know how
close I am to the ending I don't want to
stop and start a new part if I'm already
close oh I made this mistake before but
David's car he's still got to be here
come on Marion it's dark so stay close
behind dear oh I'm playing David or Paul
now okay I see ooh were those footsteps
they were from upstairs now you David
wait upstairs over there are upstairs
over where okay upstairs over here
that's where he pointed I'm gonna assume
just assuming just do the assumption
maybe I got a yeah way to say it hello
no it's got to be on the top floor
that's right okay one second I know I
got to be close to the end I'm gonna
finish this up all in one episode I
don't care of it whoo-hoo yeah what are
you doing there
hey what are you doing there what the
hell is that uh a girl hey what are you
doing in this old place
you hate sissies like me don't you
what huh that's all that's [ __ ] but
your friend is important to you right
what hey what the heck are you what's
this about I'm confused as you are go
see him
where man what the hell was that I don't
know you tell me man okay go see him
where where'd you go Todd dang and I
hate being led astray ah I was in the
basement before so the DA someone else
David who the hell are you
I guess Dee yes it's Dee yo the hell
what are you doing here all alone hey
he's your friend right go on and save
him tell him the truth
I knew you weren't real I knew you
weren't real the truth what I'm counting
on you okay if you say so
uh why are there so many people here I
don't get it
they're not real Paul they're not real
you're trapped in the same nightmare
than I am no no oh I thought for sure
okay never mind um probably the rooftop
if I had to guess that's where the
climactic end in actually that's
probably where David's trying to throw
himself off to die there was a crooked
man and he walked a crooked mile kid
don't tell me a kid's wandering around
here it's fluffy he found a crooked
sixpence upon a crooked style he bought
a crooked cat which caught a crooked
Mouse kid what are you doing and they
all live together in a little crooked
house hey you listening to me then he
had a crooked thought why is my
crookedness my lot why must I be crooked
instead of being not so the crooked man
would cry and he couldn't fathom why it
was sad all the time
and he sighed and so he David's waiting
for you go see him okay you creepy freak
him kid I knew it who won who's gonna
Sam why do you know David did he meet
him forget about it let's go Marion if
you're real - wait a minute wait a
minute
married what's up stop it
are you teasing me don't you know this
isn't the time for that Oh Paul song but
Marion didn't what do you mean teasing
you just who do you keep talking to huh
stop trying to spook me I know there
wouldn't be anyone here we just need to
find David no jokes well plot thickens
so that's it huh Marion go and leave the
hospital sorry for uh trying to spook
you don't worry I'll find David wait I'm
staying with you if anything happened
I'd be putting us both in danger please
just trust me right all right please
come back quickly
right
well MIT where's Marion gonna go she
drove an hour a day here just wait for
me David I'm a-comin for you know Paul's
kind of psycho bonkers crazy but that's
okay because he kind of fits in with
this menagerie of insanity you like that
that would also make a great band name
menagerie of insanity Oh someone take
that someone go global with that David
what are you doing out there don't open
the Doo hangin let me say before I open
that door cuz I bet is something going
on let's see what we got here David
don't be psycho bonkers crazy
David David Paul why are you here came
to pick you up I'll ask for a good
explanation later for now you're coming
home forget about me
just leave me alone hey Dave stay away I
got a gun I just remembered Oh
David you
um I'm hopeless I keep walking but I see
nothing I'll never ever be happy I'm a
crooked man no matter what that's all
I'll be and those are the only things
I'll have oh whoa whoa what the David
what that's what so someone's
controlling him agony living his agony
nothing will go how I want it so right
here right now
David persuade take the gun punch him in
his face aah aah I want to punch him in
his stupid face but now um I'll persuade
him that's probably wrong too I know
you've had it really rough are they
wrong
I'm your best bud after all I'm always
trying to help you out and it might be
hard now but tides can change good
things can still happen no I know they
will whatever happens I'll help you so
shut up I knew it
who do you think you are you want to
help me good things will happen
they never have it was all for nothing
so I David don't say that oh boy who are
you
huh I don't know you
and you couldn't know me the only one
who understood me was him David you're
but I only realized in my last moments
out of my sight hypocrite
Oh David that was bad
oh boy I probably should have taken
again oh poor David David yep ok does it
Faton goodbye my friend I don't want
that end ok alright so let's try this
one more time open door get on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur ok
alright David oh why are you here ok
come on come on you've already read
through this we got to get to it
this party's been going on way too long
okay David you you have someone
controlling you I know cuz Paul can sees
things in the darkness yes I see someone
there what's that
okay I'm gonna laugh at punch him in the
face is the real one you know what I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
punch him in his stupid face because
David is bigger [ __ ] right now I'm
gonna punch him I'm gonna punch him so
hard harsh the first huh Wow
hahahaha ouch
punch him again dude I'm monster get
away from there oh I'm touching the
monster wait am i what hey ow stop
I'm just over and over and over and over
and over and over that hurts stop you
[ __ ]
David you back with us don't say that
like I went nuts I've been saying from
the start like how if that's the kind of
thing you do say Nilan I'll have to beat
you up till you promise not to is this
really it's just really really our game
logic is gonna go now about this stuff
you've been doing you better tell me
everything that happened oh okay let's
just have a brewski and then hash out
the story man what they're not having a
brewskis having a cigarette he's hashing
out the story ah that doesn't make sense
you're not him that's why all the top
police you know negotiators when they
see someone who's about to jump off of a
roof or someone who has a gun they punch
him in the face that's just the direct
most direct route to uh getting them to
stop so uh two buddies so you believe in
the monster that was my cult fanatic
well you see it's not exactly fanaticism
don't I always tell you that I see it
you and Marian never believed me sheesh
anyway about [ __ ] D in the kid oh I
think I met him huh
that's ridiculous fluffy maybe but [ __ ]
and D wouldn't be here
now they're all figment to your
imagination listen up David people's
consciousness they sort of stick around
in places more of your occult schtick
hey that's my shtick you seriously
making fun of the occult after this just
listen and no jokes so you've had it
pretty similar to the guy used to live
in your room right shatter dreams bad
breakup family trouble when I first look
at the place it was fine but once you
moved in I had this strange feeling from
you and from the room I'd have to guess
the guy's consciousness and you were a
perfect match gotta be why you wanted to
meet the guy too so you're saying he's
calling me yep and you're unconsciously
responding some people are soft-hearted
to the core and always sympathize with
others and they get taken advantage of
the most taken advantage of look I don't
I barely know him you know little from
that stuff he left plus that was all
stuff you could identify with so what
would you think of a guy who's spitting
image of you wouldn't you hate him or
like him oh that's why that thing before
I don't know I'm guessing both same as
em think back the crooked man tried to
kill you tried to drag you with him but
on the other hand were there people who
relied on you who wanted your help what
very true
he hated you but he liked you he thought
he could share and suffering with you it
was seeking your help
and that's why you met those people
that's what I'm thinking honestly I'm
not sure if it's right it's not quite
right
he wasn't seeking my help
he helped me got back and got me back on
my feet again that's you and him being
similar hmm what's up there's something
in my pocket when did I pick this up and
address I don't think it's that far I'm
going I have to meet him
you could always not what if something
happens
wait is are these guys dead or what I
feel like if I don't go the crooked man
will follow me together forever
I thought the crooked man was the guy
I'll never mind so I'm going where's the
crooked man coming from I have no idea
David you come back to us safe I don't
want to go to my friend's funeral yeah I
know
thanks man if I'd have known this would
go on this long I would have stopped it
I would have done another part damn it
ah when does it end what it is I'd
really like to know when it ends really
like to know okay I'm gonna assume I've
come this far
finish it up guys let's finish it up
let's finish it up he's got to be the
house right it's locked of course it is
nothing growing in the planter
silly rock over there I can't go behind
the house in the mailbox Magog on Magog
in would that say Mac GaN there's trash
can over here full of rotten waste I
can't go behind the house and I can't go
in the house well behalf me F me God
dang it do I have a key
nothing growing in the planter wait do I
have a key maybe I have a key
bloody key oh oh the key with all the
key that was in the cat really oh
staying with cat blood Oh grody a nice
connection I guess oh man can't believe
it this is taken is take a lot longer
than I thought it would hello broken
mirror struck with something this guy
had some issues the water muddy smells
bizarre probably filled with blood I had
to guess
uh-uh this house is creepy man I did
this for the mad father too I just but
last time when I did the mad father I
had a bad throat but I'm perfectly okay
with doing this long just don't think
that I really wanted to get this done I
just wanted to uh I wanted to have the
ending all in one part I recalled the
rhyme of The Crooked Man
all he could do was live at a crooked
house with a cat and a mouse just as
crooked I was the same way everything I
wish for ended up crooked my dreams my
love even my family how did the crooked
man live was he startled in the depths
of despair such a life has no meaning
okay I guess I'm just looking for the
pieces of the puzzle hear that Rumble
we know is that outside was that in this
game not sure anymore
okay let's grab him a notebook the hotel
to school the hospital it was the same
at all of them my saddest memories
wouldn't go away writing would settle my
heart in the end my festering heart one
part of the papers torn mine is an empty
existence I have nothing to leave behind
not even words I'm guessing I'm
eventually gonna find this guy's Journal
I mean I've just got to write wait there
was a page in like every room besides
this one right ok no ok upstairs we go
hello Crooked Man I believe that you are
the crooked man thought a scrap from a
notebook why why why no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no what what
what that's the full of women's clothes
drawers are half open so that's when
your girlfriend left ok maybe there was
a notebook piece on them we're here
scrap I'm notebook out of cigarettes I
need a smoke well why huh pile of books
on law pile of scrap papers very few
words written on him black covered
notebook ah the rule of this notebook
matches the scraps I have combined all
the scraps got a notebook there's a name
on the back
Duke Duke Makaha nice name man
is it crying or laughing how's like
crying oh is he crying yeah hello
hey crooked man I can't end up like you
he's up there isn't he no then I'll be
going there this will be the end
wait what oh I got to shoot him again
mom mommy okay wait what oh I can barely
even see those things sorry there's like
a glare from my light on this huh okay
he's got burst of speed just like before
but it's no biggie no biggie no biggie
you know Oh whenever he screams ow ow ow
ow ow
dammit it's hard I just got to go around
the Oscar to the table maybe no it won't
let me won't let me cheat so oh okay I
don't know how many shots it's gonna
take but I guess we got to do this we
got to do this got to do this this is
the end this is the one
oh no got shoot the right one
ah ah ah I can't see this [ __ ] light
is glaring on my screen god dammit I
can't see okay all right it's this this
room it's like all Brown just everything
is brown I can't see [ __ ]
oh come on get over here No let me shoot
you
can get two shots in if I owe if I shoot
the right [ __ ] direction got him
oh really
really really
oh come on get over here get over ere
stop screaming at me get over her okay
come on now no no come on
many shots is this gonna take ah come on
man come on come on
now go got him in his stupid face dad
just died just die just die cook it man
I'm not gonna be like you you failed to
catch me as much misery as I encountered
as painful and bloody as it might be
I'll keep living so be gone really is
that all it took a strongly-worded shout
that's my fade out of this world
fade away oh look it's bright now I can
actually see that's a lovely okay yeah a
City fireplace what am I looking for
here old telephone calendar big ex home
last year
what Oh up here okay I got it go to the
attic might be able to pry it open wait
hang on let me save one last thing save
okay OOP but uh but it over the door get
on the floor everybody do that dinosaur
what's in here
Duke I think I know what happened I know
it I knew it I uh yeah I knew it I knew
it I so knew it
Duke you you detested me though I live
such a similar life you hated how I
lived comfortably so you wanted to drag
me down to take me with you
but didn't you want to be saved deep
down so you called me no that's not
right you wanted to help me to tell me
don't come the way I've come thank you
nothing will make you suffer anymore
where you're going it's a good place so
now you can rest in peace
watch ending or skip-to-credits now
watch the ending that's what we came
here for come on all my fans out there
they want to see the ending wow it must
have been rough David finding your
corpse on your trip but it sounds like
it ended up all right I'll go make some
tea me and Paul are gonna talk about
ghost stuff he was beaten by The Crooked
Man he was dragged to the other side oh
no I think he was a crooked man dang it
the crooked man was always right by
because his neck was the thing and when
he hanged him stuff that's what it was I
realized he was there every time I was
sad I felt like he was whispering to me
I knew if I acknowledged it I was done
for so I tried not to think about it if
all this hadn't happened I think sooner
or later I'd take his same path thinking
of it that way he really did save me
always such an easy target aren't you
that's why you got dragged into this
it's fine the crooked man is gone hello
huh okay I'll head right there Oh David
what's up who was it the hospital my
mom's condition took a turn
they're gonna have to do the operation
take my bike it'll be faster you gotta
go don't sit here staring doctor doctor
mom mom's condition to be honest this is
rather risky removing the tumor isn't
too difficult but she might not have the
strength to doctor please my mom she's
the only family I have please
sign this we're getting ready now do the
best job we can okay doctor
mom mom the tumor was successfully
removed she's still sleeping now we
might have a chance if she wakes up
tonight will be the biggest turtle have
faith in her
I'm not playing David mom mom oh thank
god
you woke up you really I felt like I was
in darkness
I was scared screaming I must have
worried you and those things I did to
you
I'm so sorry it was hard wasn't it it's
okay
it's okay you helped me open my eyes mom
I was so unhappy I was just struggling
to be happy but I didn't give my mother
the happiness she needed after all the
hardship I'd given her I'd foolishly
doubted though I wasn't loved was it
needed it that's why I do you hate me
for it
don't be silly David indeed you and I
both it's hard to say we were always
happy but even in the sad times you were
always honest he lived a straight and
honest life not crooked I was so proud
of you having you as a son was my
greatest happiness don't focus on the
sad things and I'm sure you'll notice
all the happiness hiding around you
Davee thirsty did you bring me some
water
sure just a second oh here you go mom
mom
you
she got a good funeral I'm sure your
mother's happy now
you gotta be tired on David you okay she
told me she was happy in the end
if I'm going to live without blaming
myself those words are going to help a
lot
it's fine if I have to suffer if I can
be smiling in the end
David
Marian why are you
Shirley why are you hey Shirley I still
ain't forgiven you how dare you give
David the cold
WOWOW I'm a purple nurple ahem we're
going okay stop it oh he was giving a
purple nurple okay okay so now Shirley
who's been hinted at through him the
entire game David I heard about your
mother
it's good you came Shirley mom always
liked you so I bet she's glad thanks
David
I was anxious I'm unsure of where we're
where I'm going I'm worried the road I'm
walking will be full of twists and turns
maybe I did need your kindness he'd
never let me down but how did I repay
you I'm really the worst did the worst
I'm sorry maybe this is too late but
David if it's okay with you
would you like to
David I'm sorry please don't cry now I'm
not said just even though my dreams were
crushed and I just lost my only family
I'm just so happy you came back
it's okay Shirley however off-kilter
things get will set them straight
promise you David
you know what I think the crooked man
had a crooked body and only crooked
things
but I'm sure he was happy living in his
crooked house
you
huh the last note said he needed to pack
cigarettes
I have to see you again until then rest
in peace
good end bye-bye blackbird
there you go that's the end tool yeah
all right that was Lum as part went on
way longer than I thought it was going
to sorry about that it's not that I was
rushing to get to the ending I really
did think like it's like just when I was
in a plane mad father I thought like oh
here comes the ending oh no wait oh no
here comes the ending ah crap oh here
comes the ending oh no and then I got to
play more and then I got to play more in
there I could play more so I thought
that it was got to be the end but it
wasn't but either way who's still really
fun and glad I did it um besides some
wonky game logic when I was playing that
like really wonky I liked the story a
lot I liked it um it was very cool the
way they brought things together the end
and I still think that Duke was The
Crooked Man
iiiiii rah-rah mostly because we never
saw him as an apparition besides the
Crooked Man so I yell oh okay whatever
anyway go anyway so what I'm trying to
say is that this was really cool and I
really liked the good story on some of
these and the story that I can get into
it and really get interested about in I
hope that I add to some of it wait what
thanks for playing The Crooked Man and
congrats on the good ending well thanks
this is an extra page you'll lose the
page if you quit so I recommend making a
save you can also begin a second
playthrough here is there something
extra on the second playthrough let's
the hand save in the last spot per
player about the series this ends The
Crooked Man but I'd like to make a
series of similar games
I hope um I play them when they come out
they'll be available on my blog about
the second playthrough the door the top
leads to the second playthrough there's
no change of story battles two choices
but some events near the ending change
please try it if you're interested
second play will be indicated play
throughs three and up have no changes
about the game the impetus to create the
game came from a strange event that
happened to a friend of the author
writing it all would be too long a story
unfortunately it might be available on
my blog
Blagh this game is less scary than my
last game paranoia yak but I consider
having more action in this one the
author will be delighted if you enjoy it
again thank you for playing all right
there you have it that's the end of The
Crooked Man I really enjoyed it hope you
enjoyed my playthrough um like I was
saying I really hope that meet reading
it add something to the game if you like
it then definitely play for yourselves
but if you want to if you enjoyed these
playthroughs there's gonna be more so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
I like the rain that's something new
up here anything ooh
Horace Felix Felix so playing the pages
always of course Christine sounds I
think so note family and you let
everybody die oh why am I in this photo
this is my family they seem to be all
dead bro might have to move on in that
regard
maybe not supposed to be creepy I bet